my question is the extent and foundation
now provides funding for the local
Association I things pronounced in hat
but the ultimate goal of the foundation
is that the Association be
self-sustainable by year 2021 that it
had the capacity to roses on funds and
manages various projects such as the
high school seeds of knowledge on its
own I was hoping you could please if you
could I was hoping you could explain to
us this model of sustainability
quantitatively and also how the
foundation will properly transfer its
knowledge base to the Association so
that the work is left and capable hands
yeah it's a process and the reason we
have fell into the 20 year plan and that
was because when I started the
foundation I was 45 and I thought 20
more years I'll be 65 it's time to
retire so that was always my my plan 20
years but then it became part of our
philosophy because I would see more and
more organizations in Guatemala of which
there are many many still being run
after 20 years by people from the states
and that just they wouldn't give or they
didn't plan for this transfer of power
and so you would still have white people
in Guatemala running organization so it
be I didn't like that this may be partly
to my my reaction to growing up as a
missionary because you you see a little
bit of the same kind of thing where
these missionaries go down there a bit
patronizing and they know better than
local people and it's just a real bad
they had a tendency we have heavy as
Westerners so I've always thought we've
been talking about this ever since the
beginning that in 2021 you will have to
have money blah blah blah and so that
but the first step was that we gave a
scholarship to young men who was in the
states from somewhat dated on to go to
go to college and he studied
management business management but he
came back to Guatemala he started
working for us and he has no I'm not a
manager I never was able to manage
anything but he came back and has sort
of built up the organization of the
Association so now they they really
aren't there all self menit maybe they
managed themselves in Elias the same
young man has now taken the job as the
director of the foundation said what he
call it branch in Guatemala so he's
raising money and he's actually raised
seventy-five thousand dollars last year
so I'm thinking somebody better at it
than I am and I'm really really relieved
because I want to I don't raising money
is is not something that I particularly
enjoy doing so I think we I think we're
on track for the 20 21